just hours before surrendering to
russian forces in the besieged city of
mariupol aiden aslin sent this message
home to his family in newark
if you're watching this it means that
we've surrendered
we've lasted about a month run out of
ammunition
food
the only thing we had left was water
the next time the family of the former
care worker saw him was on a video
broadcast by russian state tv which
claims he's a mercenary a video which
sky news has chosen not to broadcast
they have put him on their tv so
he is now
um
he is alive
but they are now accountable his family
say aiden who has applied for ukrainian
citizenship joined the ukrainian army
four years ago and as such should be
treated as a legitimate prisoner of war
he's not a mercenary he's not a
volunteer he did not go out there
in the last month to think i'm gonna
fight i'm gonna get glory he has been
out there for four years
um
and
he is a legit ukrainian
marine
aiden spoke to sky's stuart ramsey
shortly before his unit became
entrenched in mariupol he wanted the
world to listen
i don't think we need to send british
troops or american troops i think all
the west needs to do is we need to
support ukraine politically like give
them as much political support as we're
doing like continue even like amp it up
and just give them the weapons they need
to defend themselves and to defend their
country
aiden's family have contacted the
foreign office for help to secure his
release and hope that he could be part
of a prisoner exchange between ukraine
and russia
whatever route he takes they just want
him to be able to return safely to the
heroes welcome they believe he deserves
fraser moored sky news newark